transcontinental vent la plupart de ces
médias spécialisés dont le journal les
affaires
transcontinental a effectué deux
transactions dont les montants n'ont pas
été dévoilés l'entreprise torontoise
newcom médias met la main sur quatre
publications notamment financé
investissement et conseillers et le
groupe contexte nouvelle entreprise
dirigée par pierre marcoux le fils du
fondateur de transcontinental rémi
marcoux achète les affaires les affaires
plus les événements les affaires et
d'autres actifs à la suite de ces
transactions 14 personnes vont perdre
leur emploi
pierre marcoux est notre invité ce soir
bonsoir monsieur recours sur un seul
client alors quelle est donc cette
transaction quel est l'intérêt de faire
cela qu'est ce qui arrive avec le
journal les affaires quelle est la suite
des choses
mais ce qu'ont annoncé aujourd'hui c'est
que j'ai fait l'acquisition dans mon cas
de la plateforme de la marque les
affaires wii ainsi que des marques
comtec et benefits canada ses marques
dans le fond produisent beaucoup de
conférences en fait se marre que l'on
produit 75 conférence cinq salons
commerciaux ont fait des dizaines de
formations également et on produit des
publications papier et numérique qui
viennent vont supporter la croissance de
ces entreprises là vous lui parlez vous
parlez beaucoup de marques vous me
parlez beaucoup des salons et des
événements et je voyais aujourd'hui que
le journal les affaires ne sera publiée
qu'une fois par mois à partir de 2020
c'est madame effectivement est ce que
est ce que on assiste tranquillement à
la fin du journal papier qui est le
journal les affaires
ben non je crois pas quand même pas à la
fin aujourd'hui l'enfant aujourd'hui on
a un modèle qui se dit que c'était très
bien avec quatorze numéros de les
affaires un site web qui est très
dynamique et 45 conférences sous la
marque les affaires ce modèle qui
fonctionne bien parce qu'on fait des
conférences on répond à des besoins
d'entrepreneurs de gens d'affaires de
manière très précise avec des solutions
concrètes
ils en font le journal que le numérique
viennent appuyer viennent entretenir une
conversation toute l'année avec ces
personnes là pour d'enfants bonifié si
on veut notre offre de conférence
vous vous êtes le président de
transcontinental qui devenait donc le
le grand patron de contexte cette
nouvelle entité c'est tout à fait sûrs
qu'ils quittent une nouvelle entreprise
complètement attaché et indépendante de
transcontinental
alors pourquoi c'est mieux ce nouveau
modèle là que vous créez aujourd'hui que
d'avoir le journal les affaires les
affaires plus et les autres à
l'intérieur de ce conglomérat qui
s'appelle transcontinental qui est quand
même une grande entreprise mais
attestera se concentra le fait le choix
de développer dans son secteur de
l'emballage souple et mme énormément
d'emphase le dessus ce qui est excellent
pour l'entreprise
moi dans ce contexte là ça fait
longtemps que j'avais le goût de devenir
entrepreneurs d'avoir ma propre
entreprise
eh bien j'ai levé la main g j'ai
contacté dans le fond les gens au siège
social de transcontinental pour leur
dire que c'était mon intérêt oui on
pense que comme entrepreneur autant
moins que l'autre personne you come on
va voir beaucoup plus de temps beaucoup
plus de capacités en fait on valide
harju rapide et agile pour développer ce
qu'on veut faire et d'argent ont très
bien dans le monde des médias
d'information vous savez depuis des
années aux affaires vous tentez de
trouver des revenus de faire fonctionner
le modèle d'affaires moi que je pense
que dans les dix dernières années on a
quand même réussi mon père a acheté ce
journal là il ya 40 ans 1979
à ce moment là il y avait une plate
forme c'était le papier suite à ça et à
peu près vingt et un en a rajouté le
numérique puis après dix ans on a
racheté l'événementiel l'événement selim
étant le fer de lance de cette
entreprise-là de cette activité là c'est
ce qui nous a permis une enfant au
courant des dernières années de
continuer à croître d'embaucher des gens
de développer en fait donc s'assurer que
ces familles ça resterait à mon
entreprise sur marcq où vous êtes un
marcoux donc ça reste dans la famille
reste dans la famille effective vous y
tenez au journal les affaires
oh je tiens beaucoup à la mission en
fait d'eux les affaires au journal au
numérique aux événements on a une belle
mission émission c'est de répondre aux
besoins des gens là font leur apporter
des solutions concrètes
puis on le fait sur l'ensemble de nos
plateformes est-ce que ce journal là que
je tiens dans mes mains est ce que je le
tiendrai encore dans un an ou deux dans
un an ou deux je suis assez confiant en
fait je suis très très confiant je vais
vous dire dans deux dans trois ou quatre
ans dans skoda l'autre au canada peut
disparaître
écoutez je peux pas prévoir le futur
nous à la décision qu'on prince et de
s'ajuster à nos marges
et de répondre à nos missions on le fait
sur différentes plateformes
on s'ajuste selon le marché et on fait
tout en fait on fait beaucoup d'efforts
en fait pour qu'ils puissent là est
encore là dans plusieurs années malgré
un contexte difficile mais d'autres il
ya d'autres éléments dans ce lieu le
numérique je reviens encore il ya des
événements qui font en sorte que
globalement c'est une entreprise qui est
qui est saine qui est rampante qui peut
continuer d'aller de l'avant
est-ce que vos investissements à venir
vont surtout aller justement dans les
événements un type d'événement pour
générer des revenus c'est important nous
pour nous d'avoir des marques fortes
dans vos produits imprimés et numériques
rang mais effectivement la croissance va
passer par les événements et ses valeurs
qu'on va continuer à faire des efforts
de développement importants autant
devoir ganic qu'au niveau d'acquisition
potentielles
on voit les difficultés du groupe
capital médias présentement on nous dit
qu'il ya toutes sortes de groupes qui
sont intéressés à être partenaire ou à
acheter je ne sais trop où est ce qu'il
ya des groupes qui se sont montrés
intéressés à acheter les affaires ben
moi j'ai fait j'ai fait une offre et à
partir de ce moment là la compagnie
était intéressé à poursuivre cette cette
négociation lancée type d'histoire de
transcontinental est ce qui est des
groupes qui ont voulu acheter les
affaires dans les derniers mois ou
dernières années n'ont pas pendant que
papa pendant que j'étais là vous avez
pas eu d'autres offres
on n'a pas eu d'autres bons à partir de
maintenant est ce que vous pourriez
revendre ce journal est ce que ce
journal là et est une part de votre
entreprise mais une part que vous
pourriez laisser aller bon soyons très
clairs moi je vais pas faire de cette
acquisition la autant les affaires
contact benefits canada pour revendre
ses actifs là où pour les fermer
loin d'être là c'est vraiment pas mon
intérieur ok je suis quelqu'un qui aime
développer et on va continuer à bâtir
sur ces marques leur avez vous besoin du
soutien de l'état comme plusieurs médias
d'information ces jours ci ça c'est sûr
que ça aiderait écoutez si on avait un
crédit d'impôt lié à la création
d'articles à la création journalistique
c'est sûr que ça aiderait c'est sûr que
ça nous permettrait d'avoir plus de
contenu ça nous permet d'avoir un
contenu bonifié en fonde encore mieux
répondre aux besoins de nos deux noms
on obtient de nos lecteurs je vous
dirais pas que ça aiderait pas mais on
s'en sort quand même en ce moment très
très bien avec le modèle qu'on a créé
vie à l'événementiel alors bonne chance
monsieur marcoux merci beaucoup merci
pour cet entretien se servent
merci